so you're looking at your Oscar ballot
and you've come to the production design
category what does that mean what makes
great production design and how should
you judge it we have four experts here
today who can help walk us through it
let's just start with the basic question
what is production design and how do you
judge it I always say the production
designers the person who takes
responsibility for all the environments
in a film everything the actors
walkthrough pick up touch sit on look at
drive yeah and I think I would add that
that we translate the ideas that are
there either on the page or in the in
the concept of start point of a story
into the tangible environments I have my
old aunt who I've never succeeded in
making her understand what it is that I
do for a living one day said to me I
don't understand do you mean to tell me
you actually change things I thought you
just walked into someone's house and put
in the actors and turned on the lights
and turned on the camera no every
environment in every film including
contemporary has been altered to suit
the purposes of the story the furnitures
different the colors different I want to
ask you Scott when you're filling out
your ballot are you looking at
innovation or just solid work that
serves the story if if you're watching a
film and it's being beautifully done and
there are layers of surprise choices
that you would never have considered on
your own that are part of this world and
they make you go on the journey in a way
that you never would have before to me
that's extraordinary production design I
think the idea of immersing the audience
is the primary thing and I think that we
have seen production design which
imposes itself so strongly on the screen
that it takes over and forces the
audience to kind of go oh look there's
cool production design and then I think
that's a failure there any are there any
like sort of cheat sheet tips that you
could give to if you're trying to win
the pool it's different different than
picking the best design they're the two
aren't necessarily the same if you're
trying to win
go for the movie that's been very
popular but also has has a period
element too honey or it's going to
really earn intense theatricality to it
that's usually now in the bula can see
most for that raft as opposed to just
the reaction designers that's if you
want to win the pool mm-hmm what does it
mean it's the best is that what if you
want to recognize the best work I think
you want to avoid the trap of thinking
that if a little design and a movie is
good more must be better I look for
things that don't that that will allow
me to sink totally into the story
without being distracted by somebody in
the background whether it's makeup or
hair or set design thing look I'm here
to I'm here look at me I that throws me
out of the movie and I can't go for
something like that I can't warm up to
what I can't love it I think if there's
a discernible visual concept and some
lasting imagery that that supports the
story and haunts you as you go to bed at
night that's a good one too I think if
you were really drilling down I think
I'd look for the place where the
environment on its own is supporting
story or actually delivering story so
when the cameras you know panning over
an environment and it's actually giving
you a whole level of tone and atmosphere
metaphor and and background to the story
that you would otherwise not get I think
when you when you see a movie and you
can't imagine that movie looking any
other way than it did that's really good
design well I want to thank bottle and
Janine and Scott and Alex and now that
you know a little more about production
design you can go to Oscar calm and fill
out your my pics ballot hopefully win
the prize of your Oscar party